how about we close out with a segment
that's uh
actually i think there's an update on
this yeah there is so do you have the
update
i sent it to you earlier um but the
update is a school is relented right yes
so we'll just talk about this
did you hear uh this story you did you
gave him a thumbs up yeah yeah i had
water in my mouth
i read this i just kind of glanced at it
watched the video of them running out
and saw the headline
so these kids the high school football
players
on 911 they wanted to wave
the thin blue line and the threat thin
redline flags that that honors police
and firefighters
good for them specifically those those
uh on 9 11 who lost their lives
and the school said no and they said if
you do this you'll be suspended
and the kids said okay did it anyway and
that's amazing
that's amazing that's not that's not
super political but it's a protest and
it's the right kind of protest but what
what is going on man
that's all i gotta say you know we talk
about all this stuff we kind of joke
about people pooping on driveways and we
talk about
you know anti-fun all this stuff but how
do we get to the point where
912 2001 this country everybody like
we're selling out of american flags
because everybody's waving them and
saying like you know we're unified
george w bush's approval rating was like
high 80 percent
and now it's you know 9 12 20 20
and they're suspending kids for waving
flags honoring those who sacrifice their
lives on 9 11. it's like we as a species
have
experienced an amazing evolution of the
last 20 years
maybe it's internet video i don't know
exactly but in 2001 i was all on with
george bush i was like yeah let's go get
them
are you serious yeah i didn't know no i
wasn't it was a false flag or
maybe that it was a false you know i
didn't know that it looked like somebody
was trying to get us to go to i didn't
know halliburton was going to make
billions of dollars off of it you know
yeah the vice president
we didn't know any of that i know any of
that and that was the internet and all
the reading all the stuff that
that abc news wouldn't have showed you
in the 90s that
you mean you you mean you mean the media
was lying yeah it seemed like
i realized how media was lying and i had
to become the media like i never would
have thought that i would have had to
become the media
in the 90s because they were doing such
a good job
when all this stuff went down and the
news was telling us there's weapons of
mass destruction we must go and we must
you know start this war i was i was like
what that doesn't make any sense
i i was i was just a teenager though but
i was also like a
rebellious rap scallion who was like
whatever the authorities said must like
i would be like you're wrong
because i'm smarter than you and i'm 15.
the iraq thing i was more on
on edge about because they said before
iraq once someone slipped one time and
said when we go into iraq and it was
before we'd ever gone
and and my dad told me on the phone i
was like 2003. yeah they're talking
about going into iraq all of a sudden
and i was like what
what yep and they were talking about
iran for a long time and then trump
hires bolton and bolton said something
like
this time next year we'll be celebrating
in tehran and i'm like
there's a thing we're talking about
seven countries in seven years it's like
a military
yeah yeah yeah and we've actually got a
war with a lot of them it's and i don't
know if that's real though you know
someone look when it comes to
predictions i could sit here and be like
at some point we will go to war in korea
and then people like and then 10 years
back he was right and like you know
whatever
right so people said these countries
were going to go to war with them like
we've gone to war with like four of them
yeah
like cuba north korea it's countries
that aren't on the opec
well no those countries haven't gone to
war with yet right but they were on the
list but other countries like
syria and libya and stuff like that we
didn't go to we didn't necessarily go to
war with them we kind of did
in libya and iraq and afghanistan the
airstrikes and stuff
but uh the main issue i bring this up is
just like
it's crazy to me that we're at this
point where it is more
publicly acceptable to say cops are evil
and cops are bad
than it is to honor those who died on 9
11.
oh that's weird yeah well look you could
you think they could have
they could they could run out waving a
black lives matter flag i think i would
not even have
noticed that they were had a weird flag
if they hadn't made a story about it it
just looked like three cool flags
american flags yeah three american flags
one was deep blue
one was regular they'll paint black
lives matter in the streets
but blue lives matter isn't allowed
they'll tell you it's not political we
gotta start waving those flags
next to each other no i disagree
i think the black lives matter
organization is is
extremist they want to they want to
defund the police and they want to
disrupt the nuclear family
and i'm not even a conservative i'm i'm
a lefty urban liberal type dude and i
understand the importance
of family and they want to disrupt that
why it's like scientifically proven that
family structure is good for kids
like maybe they took the black pill they
want to burn everything down that's the
what is it the uh the nihilist pill
yeah like like everything's bad they've
given up and they're bored and they have
power now because they're in their early
20s and they can finally
you saw that video earlier of the cops
who got ambushed
oh my god yeah dude yeah dude that's
rough did that just happen
uh i think it just happened i think that
was just from a couple days ago
tulsa shooting so for those for those
that didn't see it uh two cops got shot
in uh
in tulsa one of them died and it is one
of the most horrifying body camera
footage release i've ever seen
because these cops did everything right
they pulled the guy over who was
breaking the law they told him to get
out of the vehicle he wouldn't do it
they use taser and pepper spray
they told him 40 times 40 times get out
of the vehicle very clear they didn't
want to hurt him and they didn't they
didn't want to kill him they didn't want
it to become another
riot scandal and then while he was
crying and saying you're hurting me
you're
he was actually reaching under his seat
to grab his gun
and then he did and that the gun is
probably why
he didn't want to get out of the car he
needed to get to his gun
no no he he he knew that getting pulled
over meant they'd find the illegal gun
oh okay and he was done
so he decided he'd rather he didn't want
like so for those that
have seen the video look this dude was
not trying to just shoot cops to escape
he waited he took his time to try and
execute one of the cops
yeah he like stopped and aimed he could
have yeah and then he fled
um so yeah i was going to ask something
i remember but he pointed at the cop
like took his time
he like claimed it all right gripped
with both hands aimed at the head and
put a bolt in the cops head
that cop survived so i i bring that up
the same point with this uh
so apparently the school is relented and
i i don't know exactly what happened but
that's great
yeah yeah yeah yeah but like i'm just
i'm just bringing it up as like a
the final you know quick segment is just
how do we get to this point man
where we're in this country where
everybody's got cops
everybody if you if even if you live in
the middle of nowhere you've got a
sheriff or something
you've probably talked to and maybe you
don't really see them their state patrol
but cops are everywhere you talk to them
you might have a negative interaction
because they give you a ticket it's like
yeah you're speeding
otherwise what's cop gonna pull you over
for i've had cops help
you know like get locked out of your car
or something you pull over the highway
and they're like what's going on
anything i can help you with
definitely when i'm speeding and i get
pulled over i'll thank the cop because
it's
dangerous to speed and if i'm doing that
i really shouldn't be
i mean i wouldn't thank the cop i do i
like how you got me every time i'm like
thank you
i wouldn't say anything i'd be like well
so uh i've never actually
gotten a ticket for speeding i've sped
before
the one time i was really speeding like
crazy i was in the middle of nowhere
like
like far west illinois just like total
back roads
and so there was nothing so i was like
screw it and i slammed the gas and i was
going like 80. and that was like
you know what is that like it was like i
was going like 30 miles over the limit
and then i see a cop way up in the
distance and i'm like okay i'll slow
down
when i pass him he pulls out and starts
following me and i'm like oh no oh geez
and then he pulls me over and he was
like you were speeding and i was like
yeah and he's like
hold on and he came back he gave me a
warning he's like slow down kid and i
was like
i'm not speeding anymore yeah and that
was all it took
i guess he like he ran my plate so i was
like no tickets or anything or whatever
and he was just like here's your warning
slow down and i was like yeah yeah
because you can kill other people when
you're speeding that's totally totally
that's true
so it's like i've you you can have a
negative interaction with cops but don't
we
still have to recognize well you know
what i'm just gonna say it
defund the place is only pop only
possible because they've successfully
demoralized us as a society
we're at the point now where people are
like i guess it's okay to say
uh the police are bad well how spoiled
are we to live in a world so
peaceful and organized that we feel like
we can say
screw the police yeah you need them are
you serious and then you have poor
uh poor people in like minority
communities they're like we need more
police
police yeah the crime is out of control
it's it's these these like uh uh it's
interesting what is this like a high
school
so it's these like progressive white you
know social justice areas yeah so the
headline doesn't
encapsulate this very well but they were
put back on active status and that's
what they say
oh okay okay are back but they are they
going to let them wave the flags i
believe so
it says uh the local schools uh
little miami local schools is saddened
to see this story take such a negative
turn the district enjoys an outstanding
relationship with our local police and
fire agents it's not about local police
it's about
9 11 dude i know well yeah he went on to
reference an event that they had later
in the day to honor the anniversary of 9
11.
so this is something they took seriously
my understanding too
is that they didn't have permission to
fly the flags why they didn't give them
permission i don't know
but and they were getting busted because
they didn't have permission not because
of the flags they were flying
i guess but they should have given them
permission to fly those flags
right because it was 911 it was
important to them i'll tell you what man
take a look at this story it's from uh
february
9 11 memorial vandalized in plymouth
less than a week after town's other
landmarks were defaced this is so
depressing
dude it's a 9 11 memorial and they
knocked it over
you know what this is this is crazy it's
a fire wow dude
i was saying this earlier you want to
you want to have an argument about the
police use of force police brutality
absolutely and we can talk about police
reform and the appropriate changes
you want to talk about the firefighters
and cops on 911 who saw explosion in the
sky and debris
raining down to people screaming and as
everyone ran to safety they ran
into the buildings and ended up getting
crushed sacrificing themselves to try
and save people
and many people got pulled out by these
cops and firefighters made it to safety
and those people lost their lives
and so we build little statues for them
because we always want to remember that
this is the
the troop the moment you know humanity
does the best
and then some lunatic desecrates it
knocking it over so they i read that
they did repair there's an old story
but just like seeing these kids running
out with these flags and i'm like i want
to stand and salute these kids be like
yes
that's what humanity is all about the
people on 9 11 saw the explosion saw the
fire and debris and they could have ran
away
and they they got on their cars they
jumped on those fire trucks and they
said we gotta get there as fast as
possible they need us
and then they died and many of these
people who who went down there and were
helping after the fact and even there in
the day suffered
the horrifying lung diseases from
breathing all this stuff in for decades
i worked there at ground zero and we had
to get those breathalyzer tests i
started in october and by november we
were getting like
breathing things you had to certify that
you weren't sick before
you got there to like see if you had the
illness or whatever
the test of it could you imagine you
know not
some people lost their lives but others
they they put themselves in a position
to suffer for decades
to save people the people who got this
lung and that's why it was so
it was so impressive to see jon stewart
fighting so hard i just saw him talk
about that today i think it was
yeah is there good news or is there bad
news i think he was just out talking
about it
because he praised trump before and he
said that trump was the only one who was
helping these guys and it sickens me how
the media just like
it has to be bad about trump it can
never be good and
jon stewart good dude um i don't know
where we're at right now so i don't know
where the funding is at but
this you know this story man makes me
really angry especially when you see
these body camera video stuff gets
really
get released you see how i think it was
in portland they didn't have enough
chinook helicopters to put out the fires
because they're over in afghanistan
is that true though oh well maybe it was
a fake article but i think some of the
the things that we could have used to
protect our own country were overseas
i.e you know that's true period
like the people you know like the just
if we spend a lot of money here in the
us build things and send them overseas
but we do a bunch of nation building in
these countries other countries that's
why i'm like yo man we got flint we got
to fix them pipes yeah that's what
military could be used for is building
infrastructure yeah
you're right ian and you sound like a
trump supporting republican i do
love trump as a human but as a president
let it be known
i think he's got i would give him a 68
out of 100. yeah that's pretty good yeah
i mean you know what about biden fort
seventeen
he's just immediately seventeen yeah i
thought about it earlier
seventeen neither of them are my top
humans or like elon musk
ninety ninety eight maybe even he's like
one of my favorites
sometimes yeah yeah he likes memes who
gets 100
i don't think there are any but you got
to pick one i don't know like who's the
100 what about joe rogan
i'd love to pretty much office what he
doesn't want that job no i mean like
musk isn't in office no i know but musk
does weird things where he like tweets
and then stock crashes
like what about joe joe doesn't do
anything he's not an american either so
he can't
be president it's not about president
would be a great president
i don't know about that i think he'd be
great because he's good at listening he
doesn't it's true
and that's your job is just make sure
stuff doesn't go crazy that's like your
main job
i'm just saying like you you gave elon
musk a 90. he's not a president
don't you think rogan would be higher oh
he's just a guy who talks to people and
you know
um and he's a comedian and he's a
commentator
and he's got a dog he'd be pretty good
like what what what are the bad things
less than muscle well he's not supe he
is pretty intelligent he's not like
super no we're talking we're talking
about like uh
in terms of like their job and and the
benefits yeah joe be great because he'd
keep people calm
and he'd listen to as many scientists
what do you think
you think elon musk would be a good
president yeah because he's a science
guy he knows all the technology we need
to fix things
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you